vean este rayo de luz cuando entra a un
medio nuevo como el agua su ruta se va a
doblar y mientras mayor sea el índice de
refracción del nuevo medio más se va a
doblar este rayo de luz al menos
comparada con la dirección inicial que
tenía en el aire y esto viene de la ley
de snl ya que el índice de refracción es
más grande el ángulo de la luz
refractada debe ser menor y para tener
un ángulo menor que el de la línea
normal el rayo de luz tiene que doblarse
más de como estaba en su dirección
inicial pero aquí está lo interesante
cuando enviamos luz blanca que es una
forma comprimida de todas las longitudes
de onda visibles los colores se van a
dispersar y se van a separar entre sí a
esta separación de la luz les llamamos
dispersión y por qué ocurre esta
dispersión la razón de la dispersión es
que el índice de refracción para el agua
y para otros materiales es una función
de la longitud de onda de la luz por
ejemplo si ustedes le preguntan a un
físico cuál es el
de refracción del agua la mayoría de las
fuentes les dirán que el índice de
refracción del agua es 1.33 pero estos
físicos o estas fuentes en realidad
quieren decir que el índice de
refracción de la luz es casi 1.33 para
todo el rango de longitudes de onda
visibles sin embargo cada una de las
diferentes longitudes de onda de la luz
visible tendrán un índice de refracción
ligeramente diferente en el agua
el índice de refracción de la luz roja
en el agua es de 1.33 pero el índice de
refracción de la luz azul en el agua es
de 1.34 de hecho para la mayoría de los
materiales mientras menor sea la
longitud de onda de la onda de luz el
índice de refracción será mayor lo que
significa que longitudes pequeñas de
onda se van a doblar más que las ondas
con una mayor longitud de onda y esto va
a ocurrir en la mayoría de los
materiales y es por eso que en el agua
la luz
es la que más se dobla ya que es la que
tiene la menor longitud de onda al menos
para el espectro visible la luz azul se
va a doblar un poquito menos la luz
verde se doblará un poquito menos la luz
amarilla se doblará menos que la luz
verde la luz naranja se va a doblar un
poco menos y la luz roja es la que menos
se va a doblar así que recuerden que la
dispersión y el patrón de arco iris que
surge vienen del hecho de que la mayoría
de los materiales tienen un índice de
refracción que es una función de la
longitud de onda de la luz y que en la
mayoría de los materiales mientras más
pequeña sea la longitud de onda mayor
será el índice de refracción y más se
doblará la luz